enchanté moi c'est moomin écouter ça les
stars de cinéma les people et les
aristocrates m à boire du champagne sur
les terrasses ensoleillées de la riviera
jean-samuel avance pourquoi n'y at on
pas sur la ribera
pourquoi pas avec un peu de chance nous
traverserons l'oeil du cyclone
on a perdu l'érable
non je suis pas frais là la riviera
c'est tellement excitant
j'ai envie de tout grâce
la suite royale j'espère qu'elle sera à
votre convenance
mama trouve la chambre trop grande alors
on va tous habités sur lui j'ai toujours
été fasciné par les gens qui osent faire
preuve d'excentricité je suis le marquis
manga gare et les amis claque tresco
vous êtes tout à fait divines févr cycle
art et audrey glamour votre rat bouvard
ravie je vais fait à partir d'un rideau
de la chambière manas o si seulement je
pouvais vivre tel un coquelicot dans un
prêt c'est la vie pour laquelle je suis
né
ils ont dû être prévenus de notre
arrivée
votre nom mon mimi de mines de la vallée
du même nom tavagna sa musique